près de la ville les stigmates de la
guerre sont visibles gracové est l'une
des 30 localités reprises aux Russes
lors de la contre-offensive ukrainienne
dans la région de kerki série bolvinov
est chargée de faire l'état des lieux de
la situation et des exactions russes
les victimes ont une blessure par balle
derrière la tête et leurs oreilles ont
été coupées
plusieurs habitants ont enterré les
corps et lorsque la police est revenue
après le départ des Russes
ils nous ont précisé où étaient les
corps
les autorités ukrainiennes disons
découvrir dans toutes les villes
libérées la contre-offensive porte sur
trois fronts dont la région de kerkheve
à l'est dans le don-basse vers cramator
et au sud vers la ville de Kerson le
président ukrainien se félicite de ses
avancées et encourage les habitants à
témoigner
je demande à tous les Ukrainiens dont
les territoires libérés s'il vous plaît
racontez à nos forces tous les crimes
commis par l'occupant sur le sol
ukrainien de leur côté les Russes
tentent de reprendre le contrôle de la
situation de nombreux renforts ont ainsi
été envoyés vers la ligne de front
Moscou a aussi reconnu la progression
très nette et très rapide de l'armée
ukrainienne face au repyrus fief peut
aussi se targuer d'engranger les
soutiens financiers à l'Union européenne
vient de débloquer une aide de 5
milliards d'euros pour le pays les
États-Unis eux prévoient une nouvelle
tranche d'aide de 2 milliards 800
millions de dollars portant à plus de 15
milliards de dollars le soutien
financier des États-Unis depuis le début
du confort